hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
Westworld season 3 episode 6 trailer
breakdown this is by far the most
interesting episode trailer they put out
the season I'll do a scene-by-scene look
at that and then we'll discuss some
ideas about where season 3 is headed
quick spoiler warning this video will
contain spoilers for everything that's
happened in West world through season 3
episode 5 and I will be speculating on
future events if you're not caught up
then this video won't be for you with
that out of the way let's jump in the
trailer opens with made rest in her
Warworld clothes talking to a naked
Dolores this is in a park setting which
resembles the room under Ford's house in
Sector 17 I'm not sure how important
that is though since we can tell from
the aspect ratio change in black bars
that this takes place in a simulation
Dolores looks up and says hello Maeve
after that we get several scenes that
flash quickly on the screen we see Maeve
in the valley beyond she's by herself
initially looking at the landscape and
for what it's worth these shots are
letterboxed as well but that's
consistent with all shots of the sublime
aka the valley beyond that we've seen in
that flash it cuts to the sequence of
may walking with her daughter in the
field that we've seen her revisit in her
memories this was also part of the park
promo video that may have saw when she
walked around the Mesa speaking of the
Mesa we see a shot a bit from above at
the end of episode 5 we saw Dolores and
Caleb board a plane and based on this in
a shot we have of them on horseback
later it looks like they may have been
traveling to the park it could be
connected with this bag that we saw
delivered by a rico carrier in the
hangar we see that now on Dolores horse
either way the shots of the park do not
have black bars that indicates that
these Westworld shots aren't in a
simulation and it looks like we'll be
spending time in the park during this
episode there is a shot of char Loras
picking up a gun she takes it from a
wall safe which she closes based on her
clothes and the furniture it looks like
she's in her office at the del O's
headquarters a little bit later we see
her in the same clothes outside
meaning with Ciroc so it looks like
she's grabbing this gun to arm herself
before he arrives we see her looking on
as his craft lands later in the trailer
we see them walking away together from
the craft with his guards or assistants
behind them we also see a shot of him
turning to her in conversation in her
office and the voiceover we hear a
continuation of Maeve and Dolores
conversation in the simulation Maeve
says it's not right for one person to
have all that power to which Dolores
responds says the woman who can control
us with her mind there's a shot of Maeve
waking up in a simulation that takes
place in war world cut in between some
of the shots of Charlotte and Ciroc we
see Maeve in war world it's not clear
what's going on there beyond the fact
that it is a simulation to me it looks
like she's acquainting herself with
those powers that Dolores is referring
to which we saw her use in the real
world in the Yakuza sequence in war
world it looks like she's testing
herself to better understand what she's
capable of one other shot to mention in
the sequences of a control unit being
attached to some device we saw something
similar to this in episode 2 when Mae
figured out that she was in the
simulation in that episode this looks
like similar technology but it's not the
same setup that we saw in surak's
laboratory that's interesting but I
can't make out enough in the background
to say where this is after that we see
the men in black at the re-education
Center he's wearing a straitjacket and
they're leading him down a hall he gets
strapped into a chair by two men and
then we see a close-up of his face
that's followed by a shot of him wearing
goggles while the men try to put one of
those limbic tabs into his mouth William
doesn't look like he wants anything to
do with that and he tries to bite the
guy's hand later in the trailer we see
him back outside of this room attacking
someone with the chair there's blood on
his jumpsuit and it looks like he's
doing some damage to whoever he's
fighting we also see char Loras at home
she reaches out to grab her ex-husband's
hand we see them embrace and there's a
voiceover that says I've had to make
some difficult choices the subtitles on
the trailer say that it's Maeve who's
speaking but that
seems like a mistake based on what we
see it looks like Charlotte says it
herself
either way the Heil bot looks deep in
thought and that cuts to her son looking
at her through a doorway he kind of
looks around the corner there's a
curious shot of Sirach holding a gun to
Caleb's head it's curious because
doesn't really line up with the other
shots when we see these two character
this point we had seen Caleb in the park
and Ciroc at Dulles headquarters and
this doesn't scream out proclaiming to
be at either of those places it could be
in the park but that would mean that
Ciroc would have to go there what we can
see is that these two characters come
face to face and at least at the moment
where he's putting the gun to his head
they seem to be alone if I had to
connect this to something in the trailer
I would go with this crazy-looking shot
of Dolores on the ground connected to
all these tubes this looks like it hurts
she seems to be in pain and I can't say
what a process like this might be for in
a world full of futuristic technology
we've seen hosts hooked up to different
things at different times but I can't
say this looks exactly the same as
anything we've seen before there's a
couple more shots of Maeve in the
sublime and her in war world and then
there's this shot of her screaming in
the Dolores interview the whole
simulation thing is a bit confusing
since we don't know the details of where
this is going on or who set it up I know
there's a popular theory out there that
everything we've seen from Maeve is in
the simulation like she's never been
outside of a simulation I don't think
that's true I think that when she had
her face off with a Yakuza that was in
the real world
part of the reason I think that is
because that was part of the reveal that
Dolores was in all the pearls and those
scenes were shown at the normal aspect
ratio a couple other scenes we see that
are interesting there's a flashback
scene of Teddy and Dolores where she's
wearing her blue dress on horseback in
the park I do believe this is probably a
flashback there's a shot of Charlotte
fighting with someone this isn't a
character I recognize I have a feeling
that it is a security guard and it's
connected to this next shot that we see
of the riot control robot where it's
smashing through a wall to crush a
security guard wearing the same
clothes this isn't one of the guys that
was walking behind some rock when we saw
him so I'm gonna go with dello security
but it's not clear why Charlotte is
fighting against them the closing shot
of the trailer is Caleb walking towards
the camera with an angry look on his
face and the voiceover we hear Dolores
say we're survivors this is probably
connected to when Ciroc puts the gun to
his head the background is blurry it
kind of resembles a host printing
machine which could be pointing to the
fact that this is in the park but I
don't feel confident to say that for
sure so some of the big questions that
come to mind after watching this which
Dolores is in the simulation with Maeve
it seems unlikely that that would be
Dolores prime that could be an
indication that Ciroc recovered the
pearl that was inside Martin Connells
which detonated the bomb at the inside
headquarters or that he has captured one
of the other ones it could be the one
that's inside Hale since we see them
meeting but that doesn't make a lot of
sense considering she works for him as a
mole and has a lot of power in the
Della's corporation you would think he
would want her to stay where she was and
serve his interests but it's also a bit
weird that he hasn't figured out that
she's actually not Hale he may have
found out and that could explain that
pearl being in the simulation but I feel
like with the shots of her family
they're gonna go a different direction
with this Dolores
I think this version of Dolores is
closer to the ranchers daughter that I
choose to see the beauty in the world
one that we saw in the beginning of the
series and my guess is that she'll
eventually turn against Dolores prime
there is a version of Dolores in a
simulation being questioned by Mae
though and I'm pretty excited to find
out what's going on there I'm slightly
less excited about simulation mave
moving around the valley beyond because
even if she does have the location and
the key from Dolores I don't think maybe
we'll make the decision to go there for
good we don't see Bernard and that's a
disappointment I'm really curious if
Stubbs is the other mole that Ciroc
mentioned and what that means for where
we left things with Bernards story I
can't really come up with the better
candidate for the mole and Stubbs just
sort of popped out of nowhere and
last episode at the same time that
seracs people arrived Connells
presumably showed bernard the
re-education camp where they're holding
the man in black and that's where I
expected him to be heading we also
learned that the final unknown pearl is
probably in Berlin from episode 5 so I
was hoping to see some shots that took
place there the final thing I want to
discuss is the goggles we see in the man
in black sari education session we saw
flashbacks to Kaleb in a similar setting
wearing the same goggles
I suppose this is all tied to Kaleb
being an outlier who has gone through
that same process what's interesting
about that beyond the fact that he is
essentially a reprogrammed human with
implanted memories is that he's been
released out into the world what that
means for the big picture story is a lot
to think about so tell me what you think
let me know in the comments what you
think about this trailer what you think
about this season so far and where are
you're thinking that things are gonna go
and let me know what your favorite
season 3 theories are please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon